ao longo da tarde
como já foi dito não gostou moura
sustentando adquirir seu carro no setor
em primeiro lugar acredita-se que ingrid
os danos que toca hoje levantar sim mal
quem tinha se sentido muito vago cursos
que não pensando quero fazer quando
terminar o curso
eu também passei por essas duas
situações simples que estoca hoje pouco
para falar um pouco do meu percurso
académico em primeiro lugar disso nós
estamos numa faculdade de engenharias e
ciências
acha que a forma mais eficiente
explicada através de um gráfico no
primeiro ano o valor da ativação está no
seu máximo
é uma nova geração novas pessoas são as
festas nas praças de passagens aéreas
não é problema de uma das prioridades no
segundo ano do cress percebemos que
afinal não é assim tão fácil passar a
pensar que era extra boas notas sem
esforço extra principalmente com curso
de engenharia
o dirceu barbano produtos cai todos
passaram três anos o setor não está
terminada principalmente pra exigir
melhorias que entender que quer ver e
principalmente também não sabe muito bem
o que fazer a partir daquele momento
nessa antes de eu sair vou poupar fazer
uma viagem foi um pouco o dow jones
perdeu em 22 cidades em duas vezes em
apenas um mês e quando voltar e adiou
cair em fazer alguma coisa pra galera
foi colado e eu vim falar isso aí
através dos colegas mas quero deixar um
país aí que não fazia merengue que não
te deixei o que não fez aprender a
dançar o ano do curso que tal um pouco
pra mim acho que não é só vai ganhar com
isto é muito interessante
logo nunes
no fim de semana de integração estive em
contato com pessoas e vai trabalhar com
os outros completamente diferentes
faculdades diferentes e foi interessante
perceber que tinham era pensaram e
trabalhar muito diferente dos estudantes
de engenharia já agora quem chame forma
e zeca condições quem nunca ouviu falar
a executar uma organização mundial de
vida por jovens conhecida pela onu está
ficando na liderança anos jovens de
forma que possam criar um impacto
possível no senado está passando e se
dizem que o ápice e conta conta com mais
de 80 mil membros
o objectivo desta sessão é proporcionar
estágios profissionais internacionais
pensas contrariar internacionais e
oportunidades de liderança em portugal
já existem há 104 anos e está em nove
estados do norte a sul do país
o limite mas a glória que deve
experimentar a sessão de forma
comprovada como o tipo de impacto que
este das sessões causa um estudante
universitário e no primeiro ano
trabalhei na área de relações
internacionais
este responsável pela integração dos
estagiários internacional de cá em
portugal cerca de 30 nacionalidades
diferentes foi uma experiência muito
interessante quando a cabeça experiência
dedica vita vai passar por uma
experiência de voluntariado e que ainda
tem para programas que se votaria na
área de educação e sustentabilidade
ambiental
excluindo a executiva era o piso cuja
cultura mas confia e foi uma experiência
muito interessante uma das que mais
importantes até o dia 12 na minha vida
porque o impacto positivo em mim não só
por fábio doutor khan se de uma zona de
conforto não adaptar a uma realidade
completamente diferente da realidade
europeia mas também de uma oportunidade
criar um impacto positivo naquela
sociedade algo que nunca tinha feito
durante o mês de maio após a dispensa de
muitos anos como ter uma cabeça
o anterior quando os sites de cantar um
passo de experiências casa que tem são
os cargos de liderança que é o tempo de
carga de cobrança foi incluído
vice-presidente e mais 50 diretor dessa
vida nova
foi uma experiência muito interessante e
principalmente portanto necessário vamos
brincar de trabalho sem ter muita
atenção do que estudar uma herança e
passar por um cargo de liderança e de
uma seção internacional
fui ao que realmente tenham grande
impacto em mim também do metro não é que
passados tanto em nossa gerir a direção
de uma de uma seleção internacional com
a vida pessoal com a faculdade que não
ela faça eu acabar o meu mandato dano do
diretor a no mês passado e recentemente
foi convidado para ir ao pan de uma das
maiores empresas internacionais produtos
cá em portugal está representado também
para portugal e que vai pôr um em
conversas com dos diretores é que vai
poder opinar acerca do tratamento deste
tipo de empresas e descobri que eu não
estava à procura descobrir que ela já
nadal procura apenas um curso sobre uma
moeda será a voz estava à procura do
talent e quando de talentos estudantis
no estádio terão mais do concurso miss
fizeram contrariados geram desporto e
fiquei curioso em relação a este facto
vai fazer uma pequena pesquisa e
descobrir que no ano letivo 9597
entraram em portugal 181 mil novos
alunos no ensino superior e que no ano
2012 2013 esse valor colchão para 106
mil novos alunos sendo que um quarto dos
restantes são estandes eram estandes
ciências matemáticas engenharias
informática ou seja representa efe
comecei a pensar nos fatos ajustamento
muitos danos como é que as pessoas
curtam muito efeito como é que são os
cotados estão os que são licenciados e
que vai poder
proporcionar algumas consultoras foi com
uma dos consultores de recursos humanos
que o tabaco uma das maiores empresas
cai em portugal e que vai descobrir o
seguinte sigam serviços mas mil clínicos
para apenas uma posição
meu currículo sé é surreal
a verdade é que ao contrário há 30 anos
atrás hoje em dia trarão custos algo um
pouco banal ativa em contacto com várias
empresas significa as empresas hoje em
dia valorizado em incertezas sexuais
porque esse é um dos pontos
diferenciadores a verdade é que no mais
de 20 dias duas documento vai
influenciar
não há forma de saber se seus dotes mais
que outra pessoa para aquela moeda e
isso é um dos pontos de diferenciação
mas depois de ouvir a mensagem final
seria mesmo o mesmo isso é simplesmente
porque não ajudar a região escolheu uma
forma de se diferenciarem porque vocês
pensaram mais de seis mil cliques e é a
única conclusão que já foi mostrada por
que não consegue falar melhor
organização dos jovens do mundo
obrigado